He said you've come
now let's hope you're not too late
Welcome back everyone it's charlie
maximum effort this is going to be my
new justice league snyder cut ryan
reynolds video
he posted a bunch of really funny green
lantern stuff in a really special video
so i'll explain what's going on with
that
because he worked in a bunch of really
funny easter eggs to it
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know who you want the new green lantern
of the supposed snyder cut to be
there is a lot of green lantern stuff
happening in the movie but you'll see
what's going on with this
big ryan reynolds post that he did the
other day so starting with number five
earlier this week you probably saw ryan
reynolds posted a justice league snyder
cut green lantern video
he made a ton of green lantern snyder
cut comments and jokes
along with hawkman black adam movie
statements and jokes about the rock
he and the rock are friends in real life
so the rock even got in on it himself
too
so i'll explain that in a second but he
posted this whole other video that he
was then calling the leaked version
of the ryan reynolds cut of the green
lantern movie that then turned into a
green lantern cut of the snyder cut
movie he worked in a bunch of extra
stuff and funny easter eggs to the video
it moves pretty quick so see if you can
spot
everything that he added to it you might
have to rewind this watch it a couple
times to catch everything
here's the full version of that video
god damn that's beautiful
the green lantern thanks for break mark
three we'll find out soon enough
stupid son of a
it bitch you there is no way you can
succeed
so number four some of the extra footage
and new scenes quote unquote from this
ryan reynolds cut of green lantern are
easier to spot than the others
the way he was posting this to was also
a bit of a tongue-in-cheek joke about
him leaking the deadpool
test footage back in 2014 at comic-con
like he's posting the entire cut of the
new movie leaking it online
but also leaking that funny ending with
green lantern
inside the justice league snyder cut
movie but it starts with that deadpool 2
post-credit scene of deadpool killing
ryan reynolds right after he reads the
original green lantern script for the
first time
seemingly preventing ryan reynolds from
ever making the movie in the first place
you're welcome canada then he jumps to
the actual green lantern movie intro how
jordan's father has his accident he
cut it without any kind of transitions
so you notice some of the audio
and it seemed really weird he did that
in purpose just to make it seem extra
janky like he edited the movie on his
phone just to make it seem
extra funny and extra bad there's a
bunch of jump cuts through the first 20
minutes of the movie
hal jordan getting the green lantern
ring from abensur the ring taking him to
owa to meet the rest of the green
lantern corps and start his training
i love that he edited down his wife
blake lively's footage in the movie as
carol ferris to like
two seconds she's in this version of the
movie for two actual
seconds and keep in mind that they're
married in real life and they just had
three children he meets sinestro for the
first time he defeats parallax
then number three this is one of the
funnier big ones here
there's actual footage of tom cruise as
green lantern
at the end of the reynolds cut is if
somehow he's become
a version of how jordan that's shown up
my assumption is is that it's just a
joke about all the tom cruise green
lantern casting rumors for the past
three to four years ever since they
announced a new green lantern corps
movie way back i think it was in 2016
there have been rumors that warner
brothers wanted tom cruise as their new
version of hal jordan
all that tom cruise stuff started way
before they ever started talking about a
green lantern hbo
series so there's no way that tom cruise
is going to be showing up as green
lantern for the first time on an
hbo max series so whoever winds up being
the new hal jordan officially in the dc
eu
will be different the whole idea is that
this new green lantern for the hbo max
series will go on to a green lantern
movie eventually
they are still making a brand new green
lantern core movie but no idea when
that's going to be released
probably not till well after they see
how the green lantern hbo series does
if that does well then they'll probably
think about doing more green lantern
stuff
the stuff they've already revealed about
the plot and the characters of the green
lantern hbo series is mostly that it'll
be two different green lanterns and
it'll take place during different time
periods
it'll probably be like eight to ten
episodes per season but they revealed
it'll be hal jordan
then jon stewart and also sinestro and
we'll get a lot of sinestro backstory
and him slowly getting the yellow ring
and founding the sinestro core over the
course of the series
so for those of you that have been
wanting a larger green lantern sinestro
core war
movie like a big justice league
crossover that could wind up happening
way down the road if everything winds up
working out
there's a bunch of dc fandom stuff that
they'll probably reveal about the series
and the justice league dark
hbo series that they just announced so
this is a bunch of really big hbo
big budget dc series but that's a little
bit different than what's going on in
the movies right now
but number two next big really big scene
that he quote unquote works into this
reynolds cut
it turns into the justice league snyder
cut movie with ryan reynolds green
lantern showing up at the end of the
movie after they defeated steppenwolf
like now he's leaking the justice league
snyder cut ending too just more deadpool
test footage leaked jokes that's
obviously a reference to all the rumors
about green lantern in the snyder cut
being the ryan reynolds version of the
character from his movie
i've gotten so many messages about that
i don't believe in a million years that
he's going to be in the snyder cut it
would completely blow my
mind but that's also addressed in his
funny post here where he says
and apparently i'm already in it like
he's not joking about the snyder cut
itself because he is excited to see it
he's just joking about himself
actually being in the movie and speaking
of ryan reynolds editing himself
into the justice league snyder cut most
of you will remember that they kind of
tried to do a version of that with
crisis on infinite earths in the dc tv
shows like the flash arrow and the other
superman scenes they worked into that
post-credits scene
they included this tag scene at the very
end of the crossover i think one of the
reasons why you don't actually see ryan
reynolds face because this is all
footage from the green lantern movie
is just because they weren't able to get
the rights or they weren't able to get
ryan reynolds to officially sign off on
it
like they wanted to reference the green
lantern corps and the upcoming green
lantern stuff that they have going on
in the dc universe but i think warner
brothers had some really special rules
that allowed them to use this particular
footage like they literally just copy
and pasted
a scene from the green lantern ryan
reynolds movie into crisis on infinite
earths
so part of that i think is them wanting
to be kind of ambiguous about what's
going to be happening in the future with
green lantern and they didn't want to
imply that ryan reynolds would suddenly
show up
on the dc tv shows or anything like that
then you have all this hawkman stuff
that's going on in his post
he's also joking about being hawkman in
the black adam movie
the hawkman thing is kind of a separate
thing of him responding to the most
ridiculous casting rumor ever from
earlier this week on another fan blog
claiming that he was going to be in the
black adam movie as hawkman
he even shouts out the rock here who
then replied with his own funny post
getting in on the joke with ryan
reynolds being in the justice league
snyder cut
and quote unquote being kevin hart's
real biological father
dna testing all it was the most amazing
thread of
jokes and one of the reasons why ryan
reynolds is so awesome in real life
for doing stuff like this most of the
time when there are ridiculous rumors
about movies or actors and characters
they'll usually just not respond or say
anything sometimes people like james
gunn who are in positions of power will
come out and say no no no
i didn't do this in the movie or there's
a big rumor about guardians of the
galaxy 3 at marvel or his new suicide
squad movie he'll actually tell people
no this isn't a real thing i didn't put
this in the movie
but then you have the s tier posts from
people like ryan reynolds who will lean
into the curve and use this kind of
stuff for jokes of their own which in my
opinion is probably the best thing you
could possibly do
to one dispel myths and rumors about
movies
and to generate even more hype and get
fans even more excited
which is the whole point of movie
trailers and teasers at the end of the
day just to get people excited
to go see whatever this new movie is
going to be so number one as for
actual green lantern in the justice
league snyder cut it seems pretty clear
that ryan reynolds is trying to say that
he's not going to be in it
unless he's doing some epic trolling
it's more likely that the green lantern
stuff in the snyder cut is just more in
line with the original
story plans and deleted scenes that we
heard about a long time ago
originally what was supposed to happen
is that in zack snyder's version of the
first justice league movie there was
going to be an alternate ending
post-credit scene with kilowog in
tomorray coming to visit batman at his
lake house
after the justice league had returned
from defeating steppenwolf they would
have talked about the threat of darkseid
and apocalypse getting the justice
league ready for the sequel movie
justice league 2 that was when there
were still going to be multiple
justice league movies and we would have
met a version of hal jordan who would
have become green lantern during the
zack snyder justice league movies
then going on to the new green lantern
corps movie there were a lot of rumors
about sam benjamin being hal jordan but
that was never confirmed so it's still
open to theory crafting as to who the
hell jordan of the snyder cut would be
we will get a full version of the
justice league snyder cut trailer at dc
fandom in a couple weeks james gunn has
also been teasing a first look teaser
for the new suicide
squad movie 2 and because wonder woman
1984 is still
supposed to come out in october as far
as we know right now
there might be a new wonder woman
trailer in the next couple of weeks too
matt reeves and robert pattinson are
also doing a panel for the batman 2021
movie they probably won't have a big
batman trailer ready to go
maybe a small teaser or behind the
scenes clip or some first look teasers
of the new villains like penguin riddler
catwoman
i'm also hopeful that they'll explain
more details on michael keaton's batman
in the flash movie just because the
director of that movie has been teasing
fans recently again
in other related news james gunn was
also posting more new suicide squad
movie videos
earlier today so i'll do a video for
that sometime too because we know a
little bit more about what's going on
with that movie
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for that new justice league
snyder cut trailer
and click here for that new marvel shang
chi teaser video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!